The next type of
copyrightable work on the list
consists of motion pictures
and other audiovisual works.
A motion picture is
defined in the statute
as an audiovisual work consisting of
a series of related images, which,
when shown in succession,
impart an impression of motion,
together with accompanying
sounds, if any.
Some audiovisual works, such as
film strips or sets of slides,
don't fit this narrow definition.
But that doesn't make much
difference in practice,
because the copyrights
in all audiovisual works
are handled in basically the same way.
Fortunately for our
purposes, the legal rules
governing copyrights
in motion pictures are
simpler than the rules
governing copyrights in music.
But the business models that depend
upon motion picture copyrights
are at least this intricate.
Again, I'll use a slide to sketch
the main features of those rules
and models.
In this lecture, I'll give you a
quick overview of the structure.
Then, in subsequent
lectures, we'll return
to specific sectors of this structure,
and discuss the rules and controversies
that have arisen in those sectors.
As we saw, a typical
piece of recorded music
implicates two copyrights-- the
copyright in the musical composition
and the copyright in
the sound recording.
Much of the complexity
in the music industry
arises out of the complex
relationship between those two rights.
By contrast, in the
typical film, there exists
only one copyright-- in
the motion picture itself.
In the United States, this
copyright is ordinarily
owned by the producer of the film.
Sometimes that producer will
be an individual person.
More often, the producer will
consists of a company, which
creates the film, aided by
a motion picture studio,
which typically finances
and distributes it.
Finally, the producer is
sometimes a branch or subsidiary
of the studio itself.
In this presentation I'll assume the
producer is an independent company.
To create the film, the
producer, of course,
needs the assistance of myriad
artists-- screenwriters,
actors, directors, and so forth.
Do those artists share in
the copyright in the film?
In some countries, the answer is yes.
And then complex
contractual arrangements
are necessary to acquire
all of their rights.
In the United States, by
contrast, the answer is no.
Copyright in the film is
owned by the producer,
which hires the various artists.
The character of the
deals used by the producer
to assemble the creative
contributions of the artists vary.
Suppose, for example,
the producer wishes
to adapt an already-existing novel.
The producer might
negotiate an assignment
of the copyright in the
novel-- indeed, we'll
see an example of this in
a minute-- but that's rare.
It's much more likely that the
producer will obtain a license
to make a so-called derivative
work based upon the novel,
leaving the copyright in
the hands of the novelist.
What about the screenwriters,
actors, director, and composer,
whose work is, of course, essential
to convert the novel into a motion
picture?
Decades ago, it was common
for the producer or studio
to hire such people as long-term
employees, in which case
their creative contributions would
belong to the producer or studio.
Today, by contrast, these
relationships are more likely to be
arm's-length, but the
legal outcome is similar.
The way in which this
is achieved today is
through so-called
work-for-hire agreements,
which we'll examine in detail
in Lecture Number Five.
If the movie is filmed on site,
rather than in a studio lot,
the producer customarily
obtains-- and pays
for-- releases from the
owners of the buildings that
will appear in the
background of the scenes.
It's far from clear that such
releases are legally required.
Lawyers for the producers
typically take the position
that the owners of the buildings
have no enforceable rights,
and, thus, that the producer
could, if it wished,
make and show the film
without paying them anything.
However, the insurance companies that
provide the producers' so-called errors
and omissions insurance tend
to be highly risk-averse,
and demand that the producers
obtain these releases.
If the producer wishes to include
an existing sound recording
in the soundtrack of
the movie, the producer
will obtain a so-called
master use license
from the record company that owns
the copyright in the sound recording,
and a synchronization license from
the music publisher that, as we saw,
owns the copyright in the
composition embodying the recording.
What do these various
artists and copyright owners
obtain in return for entering
into these contracts and licenses?
In most cases, they're
paid a negotiated flat fee.
However, a few of the most
important contributors--
for example, the key actors
and perhaps the director--
may negotiate a share of the back-end
profits generated by the film.
So, to return to our
story, the producer,
which now owns the copyright
in the completed film,
typically enters into a perpetual
worldwide-- sometimes universewide--
distribution agreement with a
major motion picture studio.
Like the music publisher,
who figured so prominently
in the previous section of
this lecture, the studio
then typically makes money by
issuing a series of licenses
to companies that wish to
present the film to consumers
in one way or another.
Typically, the first
set of such licenses
is granted to theaters, which then
show the film to their patrons,
collecting box office revenues.
The terms of the deals between
the studios and the theaters
have changed dramatically over time.
Nowadays, when the dust settles,
typically between 40% and 50%
of the revenues collected by the
theaters are paid to the studios.
When attendance in
theaters begins to decline,
the studio is likely to enter into
similar licenses with pay TV companies,
airlines, and so forth, permitting them
to show the film to their subscribers
or passengers.
Next, the studio will probably
grant a similar license
to a television network, which
will broadcast the film--
leavened, of course,
with advertisements--
to the public at large.
Cable companies may pick
up the network signals,
and relay the broadcast
to their own customers.
When they do so, they have
to pay the studios fees.
But the amounts of
those fees are governed
by another compulsory licensing
system of the sort we discussed
in connection with the music industry.
More on this later.
The studio then may begin to exploit
ancillary sources of revenue,
which are increasingly valuable.
For example, it may issue
a mechanical license
to a record company, which will
produce CDs and other products
containing the recording of
the soundtrack of the movie.
The studio may authorize
a merchandise manufacturer
to make and sell dolls, lunch boxes,
backpacks, and other products,
based upon the characters
or plot of the movie.
Sometimes, advertisers will pay to use
components of the film in their ads.
Last but not least,
the studio will likely
authorize sales of copies of the
film to video stores and, now,
online distributors, which
will make them available,
either by sale or rental, to customers.
So that's enough for now.
We'll return later to several
litigated cases that implicate one
or another part of this
overall business model.